to get all these wins has been a great
thing you know to be nine and two um to
be where we are right now and you know
to be honest with you fighting first
place in our division and really the nfc
is a great thing to be um and the great
thing is we're playing great football
the great thing is we can play even
better and that's the real that's that's
the scary part that's the scary part for
the nfl and i think it's scary a great
thing for us
go hawks russell wilson 9-2 6-0 on the
road and as we mentioned earlier in the
program the first quarterback in the
100-year history of the nfl to have
eight straight winning seasons to start
his career okay okay sunday statement
time trivia question to determine first
pick yeah the patriots moved to 10-1
yesterday with their win over the
cowboys new england has now won at least
10 games in 17 straight seasons breaking
the all-time record whose record did the
patriots bring 10 wins 10 wins for 16
straight years was the prior record who
had that record 16 years of 10 straight
wins i'm gonna go with the oakland
raiders you are incorrect although
that's a good guess because in the 70s
yeah and then into the early 80s i
thought maybe i was on there 49ers 1983
through 1998 yeah 10 or more wins every
season yeah that didn't think of that
one that that would have been yeah all
right that was kind of obvious actually
hey you know what what we call it sunday
statement yeah
and the biggest statement of the day
yeah was made by jerry jones because he
made it clear he made a statement uh he
made a hell of a statement after the
patriots beat the cowboys
this is not good enough the talent is
there yep the coaching is not special
teams is a reflection of coaching well i
we we have these frustrations and you
know coaching that is going to have
there's going to be issues from time to
time i'm frustrated too often
jerry jones as they head into their
annual thanksgiving game the 8-3 bill's
coming to town i feel like that was a
clear warning shot at jason garrett yeah
they got a game this thursday they got a
game next thursday
and
i want to see if jerry jones has calmed
down by the time he's on 105 3 the fan
in dallas on tuesday morning because as
shereen williams of pft pointed out to
me last night if he's not calmed down by
tomorrow it really is serious for jason
garrett it may be he doesn't even make
it to the end of the season i'm betting
he's not calmed down i'm betting he's
not yeah i i i think he's had enough i
think that's why he kind of came out
that strong and you know i know we've
talked about it a lot but he has every
right to be
you know
i always err on favoring coaches and
everything like that the jones family
has done everything
money-wise draft pick-wise to make that
team
you know special and they have special
players so for them to be sitting here
at six and five it is not good it's
really not like i said earlier in the
show i don't know if there's a sunday
this year they haven't walked on the
field where they're not the better more
talented team on the field and that
that's just got to be disheartening to
him and yesterday there again it was
there to be had to one and you know he
made all the the statements about that
so that's a good pick by you that was
certainly one of my top two i think my
other one just goes with the obvious one
from last night the san francisco 49ers
they made a statement you know i think
people thought you're going abroad again
well yeah i am because they're not no
offense no no i'm going the whole san
francisco team because i was shocked at
how many people
thought that just the green bay packers
were gonna win the game yesterday i was
just even in pregame shows and i watched
and i just went man everyone's just
going with you know oh it's jimmy
garoppolo versus aaron rodgers and we're
just gonna pick that i know and it's
easy to fall in that trap i fall in that
trap every now and then too and i i get
mad at myself when i do it but you know
the the basic
matter at hand is the 49ers are one of
the best offensive teams in football
they're arguably the best defensive team
in football the packers defense is in
the bottom five or six in football and
the offense is really just average and
has a quarterback that's great that
makes it sometimes look a little bit
better than average but the 49ers were
dominant that was a steamroll session on
both sides of the football you know and
really at first wasn't like their best
on offense they could kind of play a
conservative though because i think they
thought like wow i don't know if green
bay can move the ball on us all game and
as they got into rhythm and this was
really the end of the game this great
the great uh
the great play call and designed by kyle
shanahan the big pass to george kittle
on that little corner post and that was
kind of night night for the packers but
you still stick with the entire 49ers
organization yes no limitations you hold
the fans into jed york i'm going all of
them all right yes
you know kyle shannon had an interesting
comment after the game he told peter
king yeah it was a backhanded slap at
daniel snyder that basically when they
were struggling
in
2017-2018 he didn't have to worry about
the owner saying you need to put this
guy in and take this guy out yeah like
they did yeah when he was in yeah right
i mean that was the implication sure jed
york didn't try to do that and has let
this all percolate remember after last
year there was talk about
kyle shanahan and john lynch aren't on
the same page and are they on the hot
seat and how much more time do they have
and it just it has all fallen together
and it is a testament to patience yeah
be patient you know there's some other
teams like the lions or speculation now
that maybe matt patricia and bob quinn
don't get another year patience hey no
they can all fall together like that
49ers would have been a playoff team
last year if jimmy garoppolo didn't get
hurt i mean
that's really the way it is they just
got unlucky and you know that was the
only thing that kind of hurt them there
where they would have been a pain in the
butt for teams last year but they just
had some below average quarterback play
all right next one for me and i'm not a
big fan of this guy because of the whole
bounty thing because he threw guys like
john vilma under the bus when it was
time to give testimony but uh greg
williams yeah what he did to john gruden
master of offense right to hold that
team to three points you know yes the
jets overall had a great day and it's
great to see sam darnold playing well
and the mono is a distant memory and the
calls for adam gase's head have subsided
but greg williams putting that defense
together and there's a little history
with johnny gruden and greggy williams
well i just i feel like you know it's a
good battle where you know and john
gruden i feel like he's gotten the best
of them a lot and you know williams has
yes an aggressive defense they blitz is
a pain in the butt to prepare for and uh
yeah i i kind of said i think last week
i was like you know i think greg
williams has gotten his butt beat a
little bit by john he's going to have
something in store for him this week and
he certainly did probably a few f words
evaporating into the ether as those two
guys looked at each other across the
field i know some fun with lip reading
yesterday with john gruden my goodness
hide the children because you don't need
the audio you can tell what john gruden
is saying and it is not happy
thanksgiving no definitely not i mean
yeah well yes he was pissed off
certainly hey they got some they got the
short stick on a few bad calls they
dropped some passes
i'll say what tony dungy said actually
while we were watching the game he goes
this looks like a california team you
know playing in a northeast cold weather
game that just doesn't want to be there
and that's what it did look like you
know they were like oh gosh it's it's
you know 38 degrees and rainy and what
the hell is this and uh they did not
show up to play and the jets were you
know the tougher more physical football
team on the field uh yesterday there's
no doubt about that all right i'm gonna
go with the uh
the quadruplets in cleveland okay as the
sunday statement and that's odell jarvis
baker mayfield nick chubb really the
stars of the show there in cleveland but
you know i think one of the first times
it is the first time all year where it's
clicked for all of them together you
know mostly it's been more jarvis than
odell yesterday we had a lot of odell
and jarvis and nick chubb and baker
mayfield played a pretty pretty clean
game other than that interception to
start the second half that set up a
score for the miami dolphins but baker
was on his game and this game was like
never in doubt they came out controlled
the game from the get-go cleveland
browns are a handful they are i don't
care who you are they pose some problems
for you because of the talent of those
guys we have just mentioned and their
defense with steve wilkes is no joke
either now it hurts that miles garrett
went off on crazyville on that thursday
night football game but um they played
really well yesterday and really left no
doubt that you know hey miami you're not
coming in here and gonna steal one on us
yeah and look this is what a potential
playoff team does it does not trip and
fall over a team that it should be yeah
and any better there were some games
earlier this year where you could argue
that the browns tripped and fell over
teams they should have beaten whether
it's the broncos whether it's the jets
but um i i i i like what the browns did
and and really as tony dungy said
yesterday it comes down it's almost an
elimination game next week between the
browns and the steelers and there's
gonna be so much talk about
what happened
it's maybe better for the steelers maybe
the decision to bench mason rudolph for
devlin hodge is the best decision mike
tomlin made from the standpoint of
taking some of the heat out of what's to
come because now garrett won't play and
rudolph won't play i thought it was
funny i know there's supposed to be
about the browns but sheldon richardson
of the browns said yesterday they want
rudolph to play did you see him the last
game that was his quote right all right
next one for me the seattle seahawks
defense that's as broad as i'm going to
allow myself to be but jadavian clowny
was out right so that great performance
we saw against the 49ers maybe they
won't be able to duplicate it they
we can knock the eagles for not having
healthy players we can knock carson
wentz for not having a good day one of
the reasons he had a good day was
constantly harassed the seahawks defense
which was a liability post legion of
boom and they're building this team
around russell wilson and so it's going
to be driven by the offense the offense
wasn't great yesterday the defense is
the reason they win that game if that
defense doesn't step up 17 points is not
enough to beat the eagles in
philadelphia no you're right the the
offense missed some opportunities to
really control the game and put it away
but that's what's jumped out to me about
seattle the last few games or the last
two games especially you know the
defensive line starting to take over uh
and that's that's what they need because
we've talked a lot about their secondary
not being as good as yours past they
need that front four which they have a
lot of
assets invested into and you're right
giadevian county not being out there and
for them still to have that disruptive
performance what i think they forced
three fumbles uh on carson wentz two
interceptions they were dominant and the
the seahawks defense is looking like the
defensive old you know i wanted to go
with maybe like bill belichick and
special teams you kind of hit the
cowboys already so i'm just going to try
to change it up because that he did make
a statement there you know i
i think i'm going to go with mike tomlin
making a statement you know i am you
know again that was a gutsy move to to
to finally you know pull the trigger
acknowledge the obvious that takes a lot
of guts to acknowledge the office i
don't know necessarily hey mike you got
a ketchup stain on your shirt well to me
what i always wonder in these situations
too is is he you know are you being
trumped by the front office because of
oh we drafted mason rudolph in the first
three rounds of the draft and we want
him in there so at times you get stuck
in with guys where yeah maybe the
coaching staff wanted devlin hodges but
the rest of the organization is saying
no
we want mason rudolph in there because
we've invested a high pick on him but
either way that was a gutsy decision by
him and the right decision they were
down 7-3 at halftime and mason ruff was
pitiful like you said on thursday night
against the browns and devlin hodges at
least gives them the threat of a
downfield an intermediate pass game he
led them to 13 points in the second half
and the pittsburgh steelers don't need a
ton of offense they just need a little
they're one of those teams right now if
you just go man if we can get to 17 or
20 we can beat about anybody i mean
that's the way they're playing on the
defensive side of the ball they have a
dominant front four the linebackers are
awesome the secondary's very good to go
along with it they're creative and you
know they're a pain in the butt and they
just need a quarterback that can take
their what's what's there to be had from
time to time all right let's recap the
sunday statement draft before we take
our last from the program
sims has the 49ers the entire
organization including ownership front
office fans ticket managers etc the
browns quadruplets mike tomlin i've got
jerry jones greg williams and the
seahawks defense we'll get you ready for
monday night football it should be a
great one 52 weeks to the day since
chiefs rams it's raven's rams could be a
good one for it right after this
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports